effectivement nous parlerons beaucoup
ces prochains jours des élections
européennes du 26 mai les têtes de liste
sont désormais connus la parole aux
martiniquais présents sur ces listes
quels que soient leur positionnement
bonjour max orville un bon jour mot viol
tombe on joue aux éditeurs mais aussi
dans une première au président du modem
martinique et en 24e position sur la
liste de la république en marche et ses
alliés centristes parmi lesquels celui
de françois bayroux la liste renaissance
a crédité de 22 23 % des intentions de
vote cela veut dire que vous êtes tout
près d'être députée européenne sur l'île
eh bien écoutez ne nous battons pour
cela et pour l'heure nous faisons la
course en tête
vous avez des projections non le
problème pour l'instant c'est de faire
campagne avant d'entrer sur la
philosophie sur les intentions de
renaissance mené par nathalie loiseau on
est quand même surpris par votre
présence c'est une présence par défaut
parce que le parti présidentiel est en
pleine déconfiture plutôt souriant
gentille en pleine restructuration
structuration ici en martinique
non pas du tout alors c'est votre votre
propos est assez sourire oui ça me fait
sourire et c'est choquant même temps qui
se plaindrait qu'il y ait un
martiniquais qui soit en position
éligible 2 ma présence n'est pas une
surprise je rappelle que le modem fait
partie de la majorité présidentielle je
rappelle qu'en 2009 il ya tout juste dix
ans j'étais tête de liste pour les
élections européennes pour le modem donc
l'engagement européen
je les ai toujours eu depuis plus de dix
ans donc ici dire que la majorité
présidentielle est en déconfiture c'est
un sentiment que je ne partage pas le
modem a fait un colloque comme vous le
savez en arrivant là bas ce 18 qui a été
un grand succès qui a réuni toutes les
composantes de la politique locale et
tous les acteurs donc non je trouve que
vous forcer le trait ouais d'accord mais
on a pu voir quelques dents marche
martinique ici sur cette liste ouais
donc les observateurs ceux qui suivent
l'actualité politique sont assez
d'accord pour dire qu emmanuel macron et
sa liste sont les plus europhiles de
tous les candidats c'est là que se
jouera la différence oui tout à fait
nous sommes l'europe et à une période
j'ai envie de dire critique charnière on
est dans un moment d'urgence est dans un
moment de choix entre le 22 et le 26 mai
tous les pays d'europe vont devoir
choisir leurs représentants et en même
temps nous avons une grande inquiétude
depuis trois ans avec le break cité avec
les anglais un pays qui s'apprête à
sortir de l'union européenne partout en
europe cette colère gronde
les nationalistes et les nationalismes
se font entendre
bon mais la réponse à cette colère me
semble-t-il ne peut pas être dans le
repli sur soi et sans rien proposer
la liste renaissance veut rester dans
l'esprit européen qui avait présidé à la
création de cette europe c'est-à-dire
une europe de paix une robe de progrès
une europe de liberté et une robe de
protection mais alors peuples européens
je dis bien les peuples européens se
sentent agressés pense est une
européenne qui impose de plus en plus de
choses et qui ne répondent pas aux
aspirations de la population notamment
en ce qui concerne la protection de
l'environnement etc
c'est la raison pour laquelle la liste
renaissance considère que plus que
jamais l'europe est nécessaire mais il
faut la réformer
il faut la réformer ce n'est pas une
affaire de technocrates
il faut que les sociétés qui composent
les différents pays d'europe soit unie
et que la parole soit donnée
plus largement aux citoyens l'europe ne
peut pas demeurer une affaire d'experts
ça non et bien évidemment nous sommes
des europhiles nom d euro béats comme le
dit nathalie l'oiseau mais nous
souhaitons effectivement une évolution
de cette europe il faut la transformer
il faut la modifier la modifier vers
plus de transition écologique comme vous
le dites
une meilleure prise en compte pour nous
d outre mer parce qu'il faut bien se
dire quelque chose d'un 30 secondes sur
cette question d outre mer
une france faible dans une europe qui se
délite ray hé bien ça serait tout
simplement y aurait une répercussion
total sur les outre mer donc il faut une
france forte avec des outre mer qui
puisse effectivement en profiter comment
demander aux électeurs de croire en
cette europe lorsque la nation litas la
france ne sait pas répondre aux
aspirations de sa population
lorsqu'on voit par exemple qui se passe
lors de cette crise des gilet jaune ça
c'est pour tous souligne tout le volet
économique société social français
lorsque puisque vous parliez de nos pays
de nos régions d outre-mer en guyane par
exemple ils disent non à cette montagne
d'or et qu' il n'y a pas de réponse
franche tranché la suite vous voulez
faire croire que cette liste renaissance
ou à répondre à toutes ces
préoccupations
en tout cas cette liste renaissance ne
va pas rester sans rien faire
cette liste renaissance de nos pagnes
mais normés et alors on est en campagne
d'accord certes comme les autres oui
comme les autres
donc j'espère que vous tiendrai le même
discours vis-à-vis de toutes les autres
listes bon c'est super mais en tout cas
comment être convaincant être
convaincant c'est déjà de voir un petit
peu la place et le rôle des outre-mer
sur cette liste pour l'heure comme vous
l'avez dit il y aurait peut-être la
possibilité pour avoir au moins deux
élus d outre-mer qui vont peser qui vont
compter parce que ils sont tous comme
vous nous voyons au quotidien nos
compatriotes souffrir avoir cette
défiance vis-à-vis de l'europe avoir le
sentiment qu'ils ne sont pas entendu une
seule zone ne sont pas compris et c'est
ça notre rôle nous avons des économies
fragiles nous le savons vous avez évoqué
la guyane nous avons aux antilles la
question des sargasses des catastrophes
naturelles
nous avons constaté effectivement un
climat qui ne va pas bien contre lequel
il faut que nous luttions il faut que
nous protégions nous nos citoyens
ultramarins nos agriculteurs avec une
réforme de la pac en vue est également
assurée un bouclier social qui
permettent notamment de garantir des
salaires équivalents homme femme ne
cache surtout et puis surtout la
question des salaires du niveau 2
de vie et ce sera peut-être des thèmes
de la campagne mais au niveau au niveau
des martiniquais qui sont parmi les plus
grands abstentionnistes en ce qui
concerne ces élections européennes
qu'est ce que vous allez pouvoir faire
vous max orville président de la section
locale du modem candidat socialiste de
renaissance qu'on voudrait faire pour
les convaincre de se déplacer
massivement le 26 mai à écouter nous
allons faire campagne nous allons faire
campagne mais oui non mais nous allons
faire campagne le plus activement
possible nous allons faire campagne en
affirmant effectivement nous sommes je
suis un martiniquais comme eux je
travaille comme au quotidien parce que
cette liste renaissance ce n'est pas une
affaire de professionnels
vous aurez remarqué que sur cette liste
là les gens viennent de partout et pas
que dans marche c'est à dire qu'il ya
une agricultrice il y a des médecins il
y a mais pas du tout pas du tout compris
les rouages mais écoutez nous avons eu
d'autres parlementaires européens il y
en a un qui permit de son mandat et que
je salue d'ailleurs mais de toute façon
là moi je suis là pour donner mes
convictions sur l'europe et les faire
partager
alors je ne dis pas que ce sera chose
facile en tout cas nous irons avec
enthousiasme et surtout c'est la seule
liste qui puisse effectivement faire
renaître l'europe en fonction des
critères et des valeurs que je viens
d'indiquer max orville sur la liste
renaissance des dominantes des partis
centristes dont la république en marche
et le modem était dans son crédit ce
matin bonne journée merci merci à vous
[Musique]